good morning thank you for joining me
merci
i would like to begin today by
acknowledging that we are gathered on
the traditional unseated territory of
the yuran wendat
hadnashani
and the missing sagas of the credit
first nation
today
and every day we reaffirm our commitment
to meaningful reconciliation and
respectful partnership with indigenous
peoples
putin's ongoing illegal
and unjustified full-scale invasion of
ukraine is coming at a massive cost
to ordinary people
to ukraine's economy and to global
stability
and it is a direct attack on the
rules-based international order
that has enabled peace stability and
prosperity
in europe for decades
nobody understands the immense cost of
this war better than our ukrainian
friends
when we paused our military training
and capacity building operations in
ukraine under operation unifier
in early february i made a commitment
to resume these operations whenever and
wherever possible
since then
we have been supplying lethal and
non-lethal military equipment to the
armed forces of ukraine and our canadian
armed forces have provided training on
the use of the artillery and munitions
such as the m7777s in third country
locations
today
i will discuss three important
developments
training
update on military aid and cooperation
with allies
first training
we have now entered a new and very
dangerous phase of this conflict with
putin engaging in protracted attempts to
inflict long-term damage on ukraine and
its people
canada is committed
to supporting ukraine's short medium and
long-term defense needs
i am therefore announcing today
that we are fulfilling our promise to
resume large-scale training under
operation unifier i have authorized the
deployment of up to
225 canadian armed forces personnel
to the united kingdom
where they will train
new
ukrainian military recruits
promises
effective august 25th the majority of
our deployed canadian armed forces will
work as trainers
supported by a command and control
element at a military base in south east
england
the first cohort
of caf personnel will depart from
edmonton alberta starting next week
[Music]
[Music]
indeed general heir shared that when he
met last week with the
commander-in-chief of the armed forces
of ukraine general zoluzni reiterated
how much ukrainians valued canada's
powerful training mission
i have also been in touch with defense
minister reznikov including today
who thanked me
for canada's continued support for
ukraine's security
sovereignty and
stability
on behalf of canada i want to thank the
united kingdom and my counterpart
secretary wallace for leading this
initiative and for providing the
facilities needed to resume training i
also salute the remarkable courage and
bravery of the armed forces of ukraine
in these most difficult circumstances
moving now to update on military aid to
ukraine
our commitment to ukraine and two
canadians watching this at home
is that we will continue to provide
ukraine not only with the skills to
defend their country
but also with the equipment necessary to
do so
through our own stocks and inventory we
have provided anti-tank weapon systems
and ammunition
hand grenades m triple sevens artillery
guns and small arms to ukraine over the
last number of months
to bolster ukraine's defense we have
also been procuring military aid through
canadian industry including 56 drone
cameras eight rochelle armored vehicles
demining equipment
and satellite imagery
in addition
at the nato's leader summit the prime
minister and i announced that canada was
working to finalize an agreement with
gdls to supply 39 armored combat support
vehicles
and today
i am pleased to confirm that an
agreement has been achieved with the
company and that these vehicles will be
delivered
straight off the assembly line to
address some of ukraine's most pressing
battlefield needs
the company has informed us that the
deliveries to europe of the first
vehicles will begin in the coming weeks
working in close partnership with the
ukrainian armed forces and with defence
minister resnikoff we are also equipping
these vehicles with additional
modern state-of-the-art armor and
machine guns as well as ammunition for
these machine guns
moving now to cooperation with our
allies
our canadian armed forces have also
helped our nato allies deliver over 3
million
pounds of military aid and military
equipment
from our allies since february in
support of ukraine and we continue
to work with domestic partners to
identify specific defense industry
niches where canada has a competitive
advantage that could continue supporting
ukraine
in the long term
canada
says
[Music]
in short canada is taking an all hands
on deck approach
in our support for ukraine and in
defense of the rules-based international
order our support will not waver
in conclusion
our adversaries are watching us closely
eager to see cracks in our solidarity
hoping for signs of disunity
and they may think that the nato
alliance can be divided
but we are more united than ever in our
support of ukraine
the resumption of operation unifier
is just one more example of this support
thank you
merci
i'm happy to take your questions
thank you merci please press star one at
this time if you have a question
the first question is from liberty the
canadian press please go ahead
yes thank you minister um i wanted to
ask about the um
sorry the uh
i lost my train of thought there um just
about the the deployment and obviously
the canadian forces is uh very stretched
now we have a number of commitments all
over the place we've also seen what's
happening in china and i'm just
wondering about the state of the forces
in terms of uh its ability to uh to
provide such a large commitment and and
also kind of on the flip side why it's
only for four months
thank you for the question lee
training missions
like this
assisting our allies and our partners
when they are under attack
is what we do
it is one of the main purposes of the
canadian armed forces
it supports our collective support
security
our multilateral alliances
and in fact the rules-based
international order
is fundamentally important to the
canadian armed forces and to our
collective security
and it is a priority
for us as a country to stand shoulder to
shoulder with ukraine
and with our allies
as a follow-up uh you mentioned the uh
the agreement with gdls and uh the
provision of armored vehicles we've sent
a lot of equipment over there can you
speak to how canada is tracking uh this
equipment and making sure it doesn't end
up either on the black market or
or being used for purposes other than
than it's intended
so
choose
you're right that we have sent uh
multiple
shipments of military aid to ukraine
that has included
carl gustaf anti-tank weapons systems
hand grenades
artillery ammunition sniper rifles
and then we moved to
working with industry so
cameras for drones the eight rochelle
vehicles and now
moving forward the 39 vehicles from gdls
so you're right to point to a
substantial amount of military aid which
represents
our continued commitment to ukraine in
its fight for solidarity for stability
and
sovereignty
in terms of weapons tracking
that is something that we take seriously
of course
and
what we will continue to do is work with
the ministry of defense of ukraine
and the armed forces of ukraine to
ensure that this aid is provided
exclusively to them
and we are
following the requirements of the united
nations arms trade treaty to which
canada is a party
i discussed this very issue with
minister resnikoff when i met with him
at the end of january in keith
recognizing that it is an important
issue for canada and for canadians
canada is not
taking specific part in the discussions
regarding the development of a tracking
system at the current time but we are
monitoring the developments
and we will leave no stone unturned in
our work to ensure the safe delivery and
the use of military aid
next question questions
thank you
that guest stands for about the next
question is from kevin gallagher ctv
national news please go ahead
morning minister thanks for taking our
questions uh ukraine's ambassador to
canada is expected to again express
disappointment from ukraine about
canada's decision to waive the
sanctions on the turbines um so i guess
like my question to you is uh although
ukraine has been asking for canada to
trade its troops it's also disappointed
about canada indirectly helping russia
fund this war so what do you say to your
ukrainian allies today
um you know about this kind of
disconnect and um
i guess solidarity
well i'd like to start off by saying
kevin that i have been in touch with
minister resnikoff this morning and we
continue to stand in solidarity with
ukraine
and
with our current counterparts in the
ukrainian government
and they recognize that we stand with
ukraine shoulder to shoulder full stop
we will continue to impose severe costs
on the russian regime in response to
putin's illegal and unprovoked war
against ukraine
at the same time it is important for us
to support our
european friends and allies as they work
to end their dependency on russian gas
imports as quickly as possible canada is
going to continue to work to stabilize
energy markets and to develop long-term
and sustainable solutions on energy
supplies
back to the training mission in uk um
how long is it going to last and how
many ukrainian soldiers will this train
i guess maybe to specify
no foreign
nationals will be trained is only
ukrainian nationals for being trained at
this camp by uk and
canadian servicemen
and women this training mission is for
ukrainian military new recruits
and canada's contribution is going
to be
extensive
up to
225 canadian armed forces
personnel to engage in training as well
as to assist with
logistics
the activities of our canadian armed
forces are going to be
relating to frontline combat weapons
handling first aid field craft patrol
tactics and include the law of armed
conflict which is a mandatory course in
the training session
so this is a
very important
mission for us in fact i
spoke with minister
secretary ben wallace sorry at
at the nato a meeting of the defense
ministers in june about it i spoke about
it again with him
in madrid
and expressed
our
willingness to continue to work with our
allies in support of ukraine and the
training mission
that
the uk is setting up
and i'll just say that
as i'm sure you know
canada has trained since 2015
over 33 000 members of the ukrainian
armed forces
so our resumption of large-scale
training under operation unifier is an
extension
of a long-term commitment that we have
already made to training
of the ukrainian armed forces
and it is certainly
a sign of our enduring commitment
to our allies as well as to the
longevity
of ukraine itself
thank you
thank you uh we'll go with the next
question please question
we'll see
that guest stands prevalent the next
question is from ashley burke cbc news
please go ahead
good afternoon mr onan could canada join
this british-led mission to further
inflame the international situation
canada
is focused on assisting ukraine in its
time of need
and that is why our military aid
over the last number of months since
february 24th and indeed before
the
further invasion has been so extensive
so that is our focus
we need to stand
with ukraine in the short and the long
term
in order to assist in protecting its
sovereignty and its stability
and today's announcement
of up to
225 canadian armed forces members being
deployed
for training in the uk is a further
example of the way in which we take this
objective extremely seriously
in protection of ukraine
and in support of the international
rules-based order which has kept us all
safe since the end of the second world
war
when it comes to timing ukraine's
government has repeatedly pushed for
canada to restart the training in a
third country why not do this earlier
what has changed now
actually the reality is that we have
been very consistent
in
offering whatever support we can from a
military perspective
to ukraine let me give you a
another example
when we donated the m triple sevens
we also began training
ukrainian
forces on the use of the m7777s in the
third country
and our
niche
area of expertise in training is well
recognized around the world jen
stoltenberg for example has repeatedly
mentioned it to me and publicly how
important canada's role has been in
training
so i see this as a continuum
in fact of various types of aid that
canada is putting on the table be it
from caf inventory be it from
procurements from canadian industry in
areas of expertise such as cameras for
drones or in armored vehicles and now be
it from large-scale training missions
which we clearly have expertise in doing
and which the canadian armed forces are
very much looking forward to
participating in
[Music]
foreign
and
um
[Music]
foreign
uh
um
foreign
uh
[Music]
[Music]
and we'll take another question
please thank you merci la questions
vivant the next question is from david
paglice the ottawa citizen please go
ahead
hey thank you um canada has been in the
discussions with south korea over the
purchase of a potential purchase of a
hundred thousand uh
rounds of artillery ammunition um i was
wondering uh where you're at with that
and uh if that deal is going to be
signed and sealed so the ammunition
could be sent to ukraine
i'll begin by saying that
perhaps as is evidenced uh today from my
remarks
already that we are
continuing
to put whatever we can on the table for
ukraine whether it's from
the inventory and stocks of the canadian
armed forces whether it is through our
relationships and requests of canadian
industry which they have very much risen
to assist us with
or whether it is coordinating with our
allies through the
defense contact group for example which
has been set up by
secretary austin of the united states so
we are very comprehensive in the work
that we are doing in terms of military
aid and equipment for ukraine
on the specific subject of additional
procurements
we are certainly
in communication with a number of
suppliers
we
are also in touch with minister
resnikoff
to identify what ukraine's immediate and
most pressing needs are
and i want to say that our
contributions of military aid have
directly lined up
with the specific requests
that minister resnickoff has made of me
directly and us as a country
and we will continue
to
do whatever we can to stand shoulder to
shoulder with ukraine and as i said we
are in touch with multiple suppliers in
that vein
and follow-up question please
so are you going to proceed with the
south south korean deal uh yes or no
actually it would be imprudent for me to
announce any transaction before it is
finalized it is not my style and i will
make sure that i have all the teas
crossed and eyes dotted before anything
is announced and that includes
the question that you are posing to me
right now
thank you and one final question
thank you merci
the last question
um
officials are a lot more concerned about
ukraine's leadership than they are
letting on and there is deep mistrust
between the white house and president
zielinski of ukraine
it
[Music]
now
is
don't know
[Music]
[Music]
zealand for example
[Music]
continue
[Music]
thank you everyone for joining us today
this concludes today's press conference
merci beaucoup thank you
thank you merci the conference has now
ended the
cafe
please disconnect your lines at this
time very similar crochet button